I feel before you sign off what you're  about to do I think you should address  America and tell America a message of  hope or something that special message  you've wanted to deliver you take a look  at their there is all around the world  there is hell like this going on every  day that we either know about and don't  care about or don't know about but  they're we're not the only ones  suffering hell now we've been through it  before we were attacked we lived through  the AIDS epidemic at 1957 there was a  flu that killed nearly a million people  there was world war two there was the  Holocaust there there are people killing  other people on a routine basis and yet  the human spirit built into the human  spirit as a resilience unlike any other  mechanism on the planet and this will  pass and we will survive I love that all  right thank you thank you  you